the city of london like the rest of the
nation is in mourning but it could soon
be time for celebration in the uk's
financial heart as chancellor quasiquato
considers lifting an eu era cap on
bankers bonuses it was part of a package
of measures that were designed to clamp
down on risk-taking behavior in the
financial services industry this
risk-taking behavior was what was many
people think caused the crash at 08. and
the rule is a pretty simple one it says
that
no bank may pay an individual member of
staff
more than twice
his or her
annual compensation in a single year
long opposed by british regulators
lifting it will be an attempt to protect
the city's european dominance
post-brexit
in 2019 there were 3 519 british bankers
earning more than a million euros that's
seven times the next largest germany
with 492
and only france italy and spain were
also in three figures at the top banking
is very well paid average monthly pay in
the sector is seven thousand two hundred
and fifty three pounds that's two and a
half times the uk average of two
thousand eight hundred and sixty-four
but financial and professional services
pay around 100 billion pounds a year in
taxes
uncapping bankers bonuses would send a
strong signal that the new government is
serious about a new economic direction
but in the middle of a cost of living
crisis with wages falling behind
inflation and even the governor of the
bank of england calling for pay
restraint it would leave it open to the
charge that is putting the demands of
the already wealthy ahead of ordinary
families the move is consistent with the
new government's promise to prioritize
growth and cut regulation ministers may
argue that if it helps a rising economic
tide lift all boats the odd yacht can be
excused paul kelso sky news in the city
of london